dan kaan what's up man I started a new
Instagram and Facebook page called one
for all okay I've had this idea for
quite a while and I'm starting a YouTube
page pretty soon I'm gonna be starting
an MBA program in the fall I've been
hearing a lot of people say that maybe
the MBA
oh it's MBA MSW so with Social Work yeah
and I really have a strong feeling that
I'm gonna be wanting to put all my
effort into making one for all as great
as it can possibly be okay I don't know
I'm a little hesitant about starting the
program and getting so invested and not
having enough time to focus to other
things so I didn't know what you thought
about splitting your time I know Elon
Musk had to choose between Tesla and
SpaceX but he he did both and was able
to be successful but what do you think
about that predicament how long is your
program 2 years 3 years because it's
with its MSW also oh ok that's a long
okay I see education formal education
higher education as a back-up plan if
your entrepreneurial venture doesn't
work out then it's a good backup plan
and the more education you have the
higher chances you get of getting a job
in whatever field you know an mba MSW
looks better than just university
bachelor's degree right so you have you
have a you have a bigger shot but it's a
back-up plan so for people who know they
need to be an entrepreneur then it's not
gonna serve you I didn't know in
university I did not drop out of
university I did a I did a bachelor's
degree of Commerce and finance and
economics it has not helped me very much
at all
but I didn't know that I want to be an
entrepreneur I was thinking about it but
I wasn't I wasn't certain so I stuck in
the program I didn't go for an end be
anything higher because at that point
when I graduated then I knew so you've a
couple options you don't know for sure
says why you're on the fence I would
either one take a year off and try it
and say I'm gonna give it my best for
this year and a lot of people have done
that and has success I think of Michael
Dell who convinced his parents he wanted
to be his parents want him to be a
doctor and he was at med school and he
said let me take
well he took a summer off let me take
the summer off I'm not gonna go get a
job I'm gonna work on my business Dell
and he was making computers out of his
dorm room at a university in Texas and
he said if I can make it then I'm gonna
drop out and if it doesn't work out I'll
go back to being a doctor and he made it
he didn't go back to be a doctor and
lots of people done that we'd have taken
a year off or a semester off and just
try to give it their best and you know
you're on a timeline like if you don't
make this thing happen in a year you
have to go back and so this thing has to
work out it's nice to have a timeline
it's not a forever thing the other
option is to try to do both and
incorporate your program into your
business as much as possible
so yeah when I was in university every
course that I had I built around my my
business so my marketing course where
most people were thinking about okay
let's come up with some fictitious
company or let me go interview a local
small business and how asked him about
their marketing needs I'm I use my
company right
I gained access to some of the people at
the University who could be customers
for my business and I could talk to them
through the university where it'd be
hard for me to approach them through my
own business
I ended up setting up my own course with
with the professor at the University and
so there was no exam and we did a course
on pricing self-directed and I built
around my company every time right now
if I was trying to hack it even more I
look at how can I tap into the alumni
program right you're going to this
university you're launching this
business you know you can try to do your
courses around it but can you tap into
the alumni program or any of the other
school resources to help make your thing
better so that's why I would pick
between those two whichever one feels
right I don't I think if you just drop
out I think you might potentially regret
that that you made the wrong choice so I
think either taking a semester or year
off or trying to use that time to do
both but really incorporate both and not
see it as university or this or like I'm
only spending time studying here right
but try to incorporate them as much as
possible I enjoy being in school
so I think that it would be a really
good experience especially just for the
networking opportunities and like you
said being able to implement what I
learned in school and the people I meet
into my business and make it better I
think would be very valuable so if
you're gonna do it then I'll try to hack
as much as possible how can you hack
your education for the next three years
as much as possible to get this thing
off the ground so can you collaborate
with the programmers is their
programming club at the University can
you tap into the school you know if they
have a school newspaper or school social
media sites can you have them profile
you as a local entrepreneur as a part of
it right tap into the alignment pop into
even local media around their hears with
this local student entrepreneur like
having the school name can still mean
something to a lot of people and so
whoever respects that school name they
want to help out the entrepreneur is
going through there so you can use that
while you're still in school when you
graduates a lot harder hey I used to go
to this school hey can you do a profile
piece on me but while you're in it right
so if you if you analyze what do you
need to make your company fly and then
how many how much of that can be hacked
through your university or your college
experience I think I think you could
really grow your business and still get
your MBA at the same time yeah thank you
so much for your time Evan I really
appreciate that hi it's up Isaiah
looking faint a suit and tie and
everything I love it I'm out working uh
I love it Maine how can I help what's up
we do a lot of content creation as well
okay but obviously you're killing the
game you're like murdering it what do
you do to stay organized or to keep
track of all the content so that way you
don't become repetitive or that way you
don't you don't step on your own toes so
to speak in a sense of being repetitive
but also just keeping track of
everything that you do I mean you're
you're so murdering it so God so I see
I'm gonna add murderer to my bio now
people get confused I'm gonna thank you
and they can they can follow you I see
those as two different issues so for
being organized I like having a day for
different things so yesterday Tuesday
was my
YouTube day so that's when I look at all
of the YouTube videos and do all of the
research see what my team has produced
we've got eight people who work with me
on the YouTube side of things and then
I'm recording a bunch of videos and so
that helps me stay organizing that like
Tuesday is YouTube they don't talk to me
don't interrupt me I still go live with
you guys on Instagram but apart than
that it's like straight up YouTube all
day long that really helps me I work
better that way than then trying to do
it you can do it in the morning and
something else in the afternoon or
coming back meeting I suck at switching
tasks like that in terms of
repetitiveness though I would encourage
you to maybe shift your perspective a
little bit here don't assume that people
watched your old videos and if they have
don't assume that they heard the message
and they're actually taking action on it
so what I talked about is a lot of the
same stuff like my message has not
changed that much in six years it's a
lot of a thing what I guess essentially
because when it comes to success and
wealth building all this more for the
most part there are those fundamental
principles that you know that never
repeat over and over again it may seem
like it hits a lot of buckets but really
it's all tied together through believe
there's believed in everything why am I
doing this because I still believe it's
just a different expression so every
video series I do it's a different
expression of my my one word belief so
that's how it all still makes sense
that's how someone would like you who
might watch a top ten on investing with
Warren Buffett
still might be interested in the
productivity playlist that we might put
on for music right it's still wrapped in
under the umbrella of belief if I go
away from that I will lose people if I
did the top 10 stupidest things Donald
Trump has said you know that's not on
brain like it's not it's an easy video
to make but it's not something that I'm
gonna I'm gonna put together and we'll
be on brand so I don't worry about
repetition though I see most of the
things that I've said even when I if I
make a Michael Jordan video and I make
an Oprah Winfrey video yeah way that
they approach things are totally
different but a lot of their messages
are actually the same if you hear it
from enough different people in enough
different ways hopefully the message
sticks and so I don't assume that just
because you watched the warm bye
video once two years ago it doesn't mean
that you took in all those messages and
now you're acting like Warren Buffett
like you need the consistency every day
and hearing it from different voices and
even in your own voice hearing it every
day I think matters I think is important
and so I am NOT concerned about
repetition in any of my content I mean
we don't show the exact same clip every
single day because there needs to be
some variety there but the message if
you're talking about these you know five
fundamental things around investing if
that's what you believe in or education
there's a lot of ways that you can
create content every day around those
five principles you can wrap it in a
story of what's happening right so
whatever's happening in in the world
right now go look at the front page of
the New York Times
how can your message be wrapped into
what's happening there and then tie it
back into the fundamentals customers
coming into you or people asking
questions from you how can you wrap it
like all these answers that I give you
it still still ties down to believe and
still ties down to the five six seven
eight nine ten things that I
fundamentally believe in but it seems a
little bit different each time because
one might be arraigned and one might be
analyzing a famous person who won't be
analyzing what's happening the media and
one might be answering questions from
you guys but it's still the same
messages over and over and over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over and over again
I just don't assume that because you
heard one of my videos once that now
you've got the message I think I think
just like putting the shirt on every day
you need to put that message on every
day until the you get to the point we
actually believe it if you want to know
what myself and other successful
entrepreneurs think about how to build
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every morning
for the next 250 for mornings I will
send you a video that is 30 seconds to 5
minutes long absolutely for free that as
you watch them it'll help you build
unstoppable confidence check out the
link in the description below surround
yourself with greatness if you want to
be more confident you need to surround
yourself with things that make you feel
confident realizing that any big
endeavor is the collection of a lot of
small steps that came before if you're
doing work that you love you're more
likely to follow through you're more
likely to do it because it doesn't feel
like work because you love doing it
terrific world domination honey Empire
right I'm grateful I understand why I'm
here I think because I am so open I
wanted to think I see it's a bloody
brief life all of you have the potential
for enormous success if you want to know
what Gary Vee DJ Khalid Oprah and others
know about empire building that most
people miss check out the link in the
description for a free bonus video